totting up how much the british military
operation against islamic state might
cost
is quite frankly a mugs game
so let's give it a go
well the tornado aircraft is going to be
at the forefront of operations we know
there are six of those based in rf
actuary in cyprus now the mod back in
2010 actually his defense minister in
parliament said that
every hour that you fly one of these in
combat is 35 000 pounds and that takes
into account the salaries that you'd pay
your crew you have engineers on the
ground as well you've got to have fuel
in the aircraft so that's all in that
figure but it starts racking up if you
load it with weapons of course and there
are three possible weapons that might be
put onto the tornado the first the
cheapest is the paveway bomb only 13 and
a half thousand pounds each i say only
well wait till you see the next one the
brimstone missile a lot more expensive
105
pounds each and you could get a couple
of those onto each aircraft
if they decide to use them the storm
shadow becomes very expensive eight
hundred thousand pounds per unit it
packs quite a punch both in terms of the
target it hits but also in the pocket
so that's the air asset options what
about at sea well we know that there's a
submarine being placed into the area as
another option
to be honest the running cost the
day-to-day cost wouldn't be any more
expensive than usual because it would be
at sea anyway it just happens to be at
sea and on high readiness
it depends on whether it fires any of
its missiles and the missiles they have
on board are the tomahawk cruise
missiles otherwise known as tea lamps
they are expensive
980 000 pounds almost a million pounds a
pop
it's pretty lucky that i don't think
many of those are going to be used
simply because they're best
deployed against buildings and major
infrastructure and i don't think that's
really going to be the shape of this
mission it's going to be more about
attacking moving targets convoys that
kind of stuff
there you go you've got some idea how
much the individual constituent parts
cost adding it all up well there's too
many variables it depends how long the
planes stay in the air for for example
it depends how many missiles are fired
it depends on all manner of situations
we'll only really know the true cost
once the operation is over and then the
national audit office will calculate it
and make it public